i actually don't care at all about money
at all
but i do care about us becoming a space
breaking civilization
as the stock price was going the wrong
way everything inside the company was
going the right way
in the business of technology you have
to
think about what are you missing what is
the research or customer feedback
that you should be paying more attention
to want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside
you two you've got michael jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from elon musk warren buffett and other
billionaires
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one persevere with jeff bezos
your stock at one point i think went to
100 but then it went down to six or
something like that at the peak of the
internet bubble
our stock peaked somewhere around 113
dollars
and then after the internet bubble uh
you know
busted open our stock went down to six
it went
from 113 to six in less than a year so
my annual shareholder that year starts
with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so most of those internet companies of
the
dot com era are out of business yeah
you survived what was that that made you
to survive and virtually the rest of
them are gone
um i it's very that whole period is very
interesting because the stock is not the
company and the company is not the stock
and so as i watched the stock fall
from 113 to six i was also watching all
of our internal
business metrics number of customers
profit per unit
you know everything you can imagine
defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast
and so as the stock price was going the
wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and
um uh i you know so i wasn't we didn't
need to go back to capital markets we
didn't need more money
the only reason you know a financial uh
bus like the internet
bubble bursting is it makes it really
hard to raise money
but you know we already had the money we
needed so we just needed to continue to
progress
rule number two stay within your circle
of competence with warren buffett
how do i value the business as berkshire
acquires well the first thing i have to
decide when somebody calls me
is is valuing this business within my
circle of competence
i don't know how to value microsoft i
don't know how to value oracle i mean if
you know larry ellison calls me or bill
gates calls me and they don't
but if any of those i don't know or
biotech
or anything i wouldn't know how to value
it i just you know i'd wish them well
and
tell them you know i think it's worth
twice as much as they think it is but
i'm just not
in the mood to buy today uh i i don't
know
so it has to be within my circle of
confidence my circle of confidence
you know businesses i can understand and
when i say understand
i don't mean to understand how to use a
computer and not use a computer in terms
of a computer company
i mean understand what the economic
characteristics of the business are
and what the company's really going to
look like in five or 10 or 20 years
bill gates will tell you that that he
you know if
he were investing he would buy berkshire
rather than microsoft because
it's so much easier to understand what
our businesses are going to look like
whereas he's in a business where you're
gonna really have to be doing things
differently over time
so i know that wrigley's gonna be the
number one chewing gum
in the country i know stickers is gonna
be the number one candy bar in the
country 10 years now
it's been the number one candy bar for
40 years you don't have to be
very bright to understand that when
people lay out 50 cents for something
that they stick in their mouth that
they're not about to experiment you know
i mean
it's so we we try to look at businesses
we can understand
rule number three have a strong why with
elon musk
the president's first space policy
directive to me was
go to the moon and the word in there is
sustainable reusability is fundamental
um the fully reusable vehicle
will cost a a hundred times less per
flight
than an expandable vehicle i actually
don't care at all about money at all
um but i do care about us becoming space
breaking civilization
yeah and i do know that uh if if we
don't uh achieve full and rapid
reusability it will not happen
and so that's why that's the only reason
i actually want money at all what i
really want to see
is you know permanent face on the moon
permanently
uh occupied human base on the moon and
us building studio on mars that's like i
can see the
beginning of that before i die i'll die
happy also if you want to learn from
billionaires daily and have more
self-love and confidence check out my
254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below when you want to do
something new you have to you have to
apply the
the physics approach investing in
yourself is the best thing you can do
anything that improves your own talents
nobody can take it away from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
become worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
the biggest risk you can take
is not taking any risk rule number four
focus on things that matter with mark
zuckerberg there's probably stuff you
can say
about some insight that you had early on
and you thought to yourself ahaha nobody
else knows this except
us but we have this we have this great
this great trick do you remember any of
them
well peter thiel was really focused on
network effects
and he had this model that i think is
right
for making decisions that as the
complexity of the company grows
every day you're going to be faced with
100 things that you could potentially go
do
and your job is to pick the one thing
that actually matters
because out of those 100 things it's
really only actually going to be one or
two things that actually matter
and that was pretty informative to me at
the time because
i had intuitively like i had a lot of
some self-direction intuitively but as
soon as i started getting all these
people around me
um who all had reasonable perspectives
on things was very hard for me to
balance that and
um peter was always very useful for for
that um
we were focused he was good at saying
here's the one thing that matters
like focus on the one thing that matters
well partially that and partially just
the meta lesson of
figure out the one thing that matters
and do that but do you remember what the
one thing that mattered like
i wasn't connecting everyone as quickly
as possible because i mean network
effects were a massively important part
of this
one of the the story so when you say
connecting everyone as quickly as
possible you don't mean specifically
getting more sign-ups
you mean getting people to friend one
another faster yeah well how did you do
that
um well we built a lot of tools to
enable people to do what they
already wanted to where you can't like
push up hill on this stuff right
it's um we were solving a problem that
people had and we just needed to remove
as much friction as possible
rule number five have humanity with
oprah winfrey one of the things i tried
to do all those years on the oprah show
sometimes people would criticize me
because i felt that i didn't do enough
for race or racism but this is what i
always understood
that for me my role
and my goal in life is to open this
open people's hearts that's what i do is
i
i try to tell stories that allow people
to see themselves and the lives
of other people and for me it was always
more powerful and effective to do a show
for example
on single parents raising their children
and just on the panel of parents to have
a black father and to show the
photographs or images of that father
putting his child to bed and reading a
story at night
that to me is more powerful than doing a
story on let's talk about
fathers black fathers who are raising
their children
because the goal for me
is to show that we are all more like
than different and that
in in our humanity in our ability
to express our humanness we are the same
so when you see
a father putting his child to bed at
night and reading stories and that man
is black
and you know that's what your husband
does and that's what you do you
you feel a sense of connection and
humanity rule number six
hire your weaknesses with jack ma but
don't
foreign
worship
the last one before very special bonus
clip is have a high pace of innovation
with bill gates
well i think throughout our history we
wake every day knowing
that in the business of technology
you have to think about what are you
missing what is the research or customer
feedback
that you should be paying more attention
to and how do you keep that pace of
innovation
very very high how do you make sure
you're hiring the very best people
and that kind of focus has has helped
drive us forward through all the
milestones the company has had
uh certainly the internet is is a great
example of that we had to
tear up our our plans and and step back
and say well how do we how do we really
embrace all that's good about the
internet and recognize some of the
shortcomings and make sure we're leading
the way
in uh reducing what what has held people
away from the internet
now i've got a really special bonus clip
with mark cuban on how to
innovate that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what are the things that you need to
focus on that
matter right now let me know put it down
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching and you promise you commit to
yourself that you're gonna take action
we don't just watch videos here believe
nation
we do something about it give me a
hashtag believe down the comments below
if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too what is
your thing and when did you kind of
understand what it was it hasn't changed
my thing is
learning learning whatever is new and
applying it in ways that other people
aren't thinking of
and so when i started i got fired from a
job selling software started a company
and within six months this was the early
days of pcs i recognized that okay
we need to connect pcs together back
then you walked around you had your 500
quarter inch floppy and you know who
would need to connect to pc
we started you know writing software for
local area networks became a systems
integrator
30 some million dollar run rate and sold
it to h r block
and then got to the internet okay let's
look at this internet thing
someone's going to need to put audio and
then video on there great and then
after yahoo did yahoo right i'm like you
know what
i'm looking at these big screen tvs that
cost thirty thousand dollars
that are high definition television sets
and i'm thinking you know what
eventually they're going to follow the
price performance curve
of traditional of traditional um
consumer electronics
and they're going to come down to price
so i started the first all high
definition tv network called hdnet
then i'm looking and saying okay you
know what it's like 2006 2007
and traditional television and cable is
going um digital
i'm saying you know what there's going
to be more a lot of storage space than
first access digital space
that cable companies aren't used to
using so let's take
a movie production company that we
created and
let's make it available for day and date
distribution where people can will pay
20 bucks to the the cable company to
watch this brand new movie
and we get to keep 10 of it and so we
had 29.29 productions we started
producing movies
and lo and behold the first movie we
created was a documentary called enron
the smartest guys in the room
got nominated for academy award then we
didn't really create any good ones after
that but
by being first leveraging digital
storage we were able to take advantage
and make a lot of money
and in the mba with the mavericks you
know just doing those types of things
and it's what i like to do now
[Music]
if you want more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you know i worked weekends i
didn't believe in vacation
and so i i really pushed people to work
hard
have you ever met a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful